hey guys it's Greg here I want to thank
everyone who watched our vengers endgame
non-spoiler review and give us a lot of
compliments on our sketch where you guys
haven't been around as long we're happy
to miss where this all started when
embed Jers Infinity Ward they so they're
gonna have their first trailer to come
out and literally the night before was
like 11:00 p.m. I just came in with some
random opening bit that was a minute and
a half to the shoot was that it but then
we got it up just in time and you know
guy gave us a lot of great feedback that
we did start doing like opening sketches
or a few videos all within the realm of
infinity war to end game the first one
here is gonna be for the Avengers
infinity war trailer number one then the
Avengers infinity war non-spoiler review
and then after that it's a vendor's
endgame trailer number one spider-man
far from home because that trailer just
came out in the middle of it all and
then of course the Avengers and game
non-spoiler review so I decided to just
slap these all together in one shot that
way you guys could just watch all of
them back-to-back even see how some of
them are linked and called back to one
another for the hardcore subscribers of
the real rejects comment below and say
which one is your personal favorite if
you happen to like most or all or even
just one of them hope you guys enjoy
[Music]
Oh world testing
[Music]
[Music]
boys
underoos I ripped my suit I ripped my
suit
I'll do the reaction by myself
[Music]
if anymore [ __ ]
infinity war oh thanks for getting my
ticket John
as soon as YouTube fixes the yellow
dollar bill sign which would be any
second now
I'll Ben know you oh hey Greg did I wake
you couldn't sleep
it sucks that you can't come you sure
you can't buy another ticket Nomad movie
sold out for weeks
gonna be the last one to see infinity
war no word from Andrew yet last time I
talked to him he was picking up my
tickets but now nobody's heard from him
for weeks
I'm so sorry that sucks man
you know man is it it's okay it's okay
it's okay
don't worry about you guys go enjoy the
movie and you guys let me know how it is
okay
no spoilers though
[Laughter]
so in hacker computer
dude great I think you should go back to
sleep
[Music]
I know
what is this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
did you know
I didn't know was him don't [ __ ] me
either man
did you know a tour of my tickets you're
more concerned with the ticket than the
fact that he killed Angie just tell me
Kyle yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right fine you can have my ticket
you
[Music]
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
would become something more so when they
needed us we could react to the trailers
that they never could
[Music]
the movies are so different other people
get mad at us we're not memorizing the
damn source material you're pulling on
all-nighter
damn straight we're pulling an
all-nighter we're gonna be the first
ones to get our trailer reaction up hell
yeah we are we're gonna be Tyrone Magnus
we're gonna beat your less successful
brother jab eco a who might even be
beyond the tre no one beats B on the
trailer
that's true she is the best she has any
knowledge as to why should we
acknowledge her we will not acknowledge
Grace Randolph in any trailer because we
are jealous and she does not acknowledge
us she was born February 5th 1987 is
written several comic books but like
hell who we let people know how much we
follow our alright man stay alert keep
track of notifications and get that
reaction up first I'm right there with
you buddy
there is no additional punchline coming
none
zip nada cut to
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] I need to change my personality
underoos John
John you there
[Music]
Tyrone what's up man you guys [ __ ] that
a vendor sport for the reaction why not
it was the only javi the Avengers
transistor
[Music]
hello hello hello mr. Greg
[Music]
I don't feel so good
I don't know what's happening yeah I
mean you're right job I'm sorry
[Music]
[Music]
this guy showed up in a lot of fun at
your Grace Randolph was in it well this
is a pleasant surprise
John wake up the spider-man trailer
dropped so early
yes
come on spider-man don't what the hell
are you doing we don't have time for
another 5 minutes sketch come on all
right sorry
[Music]
we're in the endgame now [ __ ]
whoa the Chris Evans just walk through
the door whoa one accurate looking
finish mass Greg I'll let John know
you're here then we could get going okay
buddy
well Greg you do know I only have one
extra ticket right
I can't bring John I can't tell them
that oh hey John
that's a inaccurate looking Gomorrah
outfit thanks Kyle that looks terrible
well can't you guys tell me
hey man I'm really sorry I only got one
guest pass for Greg you know how these
press screenings are well Greg and I
promised each other the first time we
watch this it would be together so if I
can't go
he can't either right Greg Greg you're
not gonna go without me are you
no I ignored and then see you screaming
once I cannot do that again even for you
I won't let you go without me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey dude I got an extra ticket to the
endgame screening is this an old message
this girl canceled on me she pulled the
whole meet to card it got very awkward
can you buzz me in this is great this
means I can go
[Music]
No
no wait Greg thank you think about this
that no
[Music]
you